[Music]
well back in june sharon osborne told
her fellow talk tv panelists that her
husband rock legend aussie needed major
surgery and it was an operation which
would determine the rest of his life and
she hasn't left his side since over the
weekend aussie was spotted for the first
time to the living hospital out about
with sharon and the kids in la and i'd
like to say sharon joins me now
live sharon good evening to you
good evening my darling now i've spent
the last 20 minutes boasting about the
fact it was going to be you and aussie
and he's done a runner
he's a bastard tonight let me tell you
now he's now he's back walking he's a
diva
before it was like oh you know the
nicest guy you know please help me do
this do that now he's walking he's like
oh i don't want to do it i'm not doing
this i'll do this so he's become a diva
again he thinks he's bloody beyonce
well i quite like the fact he's a dear
again because it means he's healthy
again at least and he's been let's be
honest
aussie's been through a hell of a series
of health battles doesn't he he
diagnosed with a form of parkinson's he
had a rough bout of covid and then he
had this surgery on his i think on his
neck right it's all and does this all go
back
does it all go back to when he had the
the terrible quad bike accident
a part of it yes yes part of it because
then he had another serious fall on his
neck and then it um affected his spine
because the spinal column was trapped so
it's it's just been it's like a domino
effect you do one thing medically then
another thing happens and another
and it's just been nearly it's three and
a half years of just nightmare but you
know what there's light now and he's
walking great he's got no more pain
he's a pain in my ass because he's now a
diva but i don't mind
but he's good is he how is he feeling
other than being a diva how is he
feeling
he's doing good because there's no pain
the last operation fixed all the pain
that he'd been in for you know three and
a half years so that way you know it's
it's like lifting you know a huge weight
from him so you know he's busy doing
promotion for his record that's coming
out in september and he's he's loving
life right now is he going to be able to
to perform live tour again do you think
yes next year definitely
well i mean that's amazing give him
where he was you must be thrilled huh
oh it's it's like a miracle piers and
he's like you know his song iron man he
really is iron man i mean
he comes back over and over
does he's again
i mean i know i know it's been really
rough for you because we've had a few
you know quite intense conversations in
the last couple of years about aussies
various health things you're
unbelievably close to each other you
were on the other side of the world a
couple of times when he was you know
taken with kovid and then he had to have
the surgery and stuff it's been it's
been rough for you sharon have you dealt
with it all
oh it's you know it's not just me it's
the whole family because you know you're
always on edge like this you know every
cough every you know every time he would
stumble trying to walk i mean you're
just on edge but it's
you know it's just behind us and now all
we can do is just you know hope and look
into the light and everything's going to
be fine and listen
10 days ago jack had his baby girl
yes and so that's brought such joy and
kelly's pregnancy it's fantastic the
osborne breeding factory is alive and
well
it is it is we're back in business
[Laughter]
are they are they basically breeding the
next generation of wild
rock chicks and blokes
i hope so
[Laughter]
but uh
well look please said sharon send them
all my very best what are you aussie uh
kelly and jack i want to talk to you if
i can just about a couple of things in
the news we miss you on the talk i'll
wait for you to be back on that i want
to talk to you about a couple of things
one your reaction to this extraordinary
story of that diana interview that we
all remember so well and the appalling
fallout it turns out martin bashir just
basically
forged documents to persuade people
around diamonds that all sorts of stuff
was going down including ticky tiggy led
the boys the boy's nanny having an
affair with charles you know having an
abortion not of being impregnated by
himself all complete nonsense but all
designed to get into diana's paranoid
mind so that she did the interview what
do you think of it
yes
i mean it's horrendous you would never
believe that this could have gone on
with the bbc that you know their
credibility that you know the biggest
news agency in the world everything they
do is you know
perfect perfect they're the perfect news
station and it's like look at what they
did to a family just think if they
hadn't have done that that marriage
might have turned out very very
differently yeah just think about that
yeah
everybody's lives would have turned out
so differently and
it's appalling it's like unthinkable to
think of the damage mentally physically
that the bbc did to the royal family and
not just the royal family people that
were very loyal to them yes i mean tiki
was unbelievably loyal never gave
interviews never talked about them
totally
never ever yeah and the thing is it too
the nation turned listen
divorced you never get involved in
people's divorces ever that's one thing
i've learned but with everything that
was being reported charles looked such
so bad so bad and the whole nation at
that time were against him and it was
all for you know about die about diana
but it's
you know i get that but if they hadn't
have done that maybe they could have got
their marriage back together and you
know who knows what could have happened
yeah the other royal thing that's been
in the news is big this big tom bower
book about uh megan and harry paints a
pretty uh powerful picture actually of
the pair of them and we have this
bizarre speech by harry on nelson
mandela day this week sort of linking
their own struggle for freedom with
nelson mandela's 27 years in in prison
what do you make of these two what's
going on with them
i think they're lost and i think that
they're trying to find their their place
in the world i think they're totally
lost you know one minute they're making
a cartoon then they're doing a
documentary on them now they're saving
the world they just haven't found their
path in life yet i i really believe that
they're lost they're sounding should
they be but sharon my point is they can
do whatever they like but should they be
allowed to use the royal titles to
fleece the system and make all this
money and pretend to be like a rival
royal family that's what stinks in my
gallery about it
yeah i i just don't i i'm
i haven't from day one been into the
fact of you know talking about private
things that went on in the royal family
when they were a part of it and the
thing is it's just their point of view
we haven't had the other point of view
and it's like don't
don't bring it to the public nobody
wants to know about it every family has
problems
keep it to yourself yeah keep it to
yourself yeah and i just i just think
that from day one they've handled it
very badly and you know what they wanted
their freedom they have it
but they want more than just their
freedom they want to be two very
important people politically yeah but
they want the royal cake but i think if
they keep poking their nose into
american and uh political affairs and
the constitution and so on it's not
going to end well i can tell them that
um
he's only been here two minutes and he
wants to run the country it's like hold
on
it's completely absurd um talking about
dave chappelles and dave chappelle i'm
gonna be following this but he
did this big netflix special he told
some some trans jokes you know some
people thought it was funny including
trans people other people including
other trans people hated it one of them
canceled netflix to buy him but he was
due to play in a gig in minneapolis
yesterday
and they cancelled it the organizers at
the last minute an issue is a ridiculous
pompous statement about how you know
they hadn't been aware that it wouldn't
be a safe space for employees and so on
what do you make of is it comes at a
time when john cleese actually has come
out with an interesting comment about
the threat to comedy at the moment from
this council culture here's what john
cleese had to say
a lot of comedians now uh are sitting
there and when they think of something
they start thinking could i get away
with that i don't think so so and so i
got into trouble and he said that or she
said that you see what i mean and that's
the death of creativity
and i i think he's look i'm not a big
fan of john cleese to be honest these
days he's a bit of a miserable old boy
and he can't stand me but that's uh
that's neither here or there oh i love
him i think i love him well we'll agree
to disagree about him i'll probably get
on fire with him actually if you're
watching john come on do an interview um
but here's what it was the statement
that really made me puke the dave
chappelle show tonight at first avenue
he's been cancelled
to staff artists and our community we
hear you we are sorry we know we must
hold ourselves to the highest standards
we let you down we're not just a black
box of people in it we understand
firsthand it's not just a room but
meaningful beyond our walls the team and
you have worked hard to make our venues
to save the species in the country and
we'll continue with that mission we
believe in diverse voices and the
freedom of art artistic expression but
in honoring that we lost sight of the
impacts would have i mean what a load of
old guff
right what they really
what they really mean is it's just we
are going to decide what you're allowed
to find funny that's it
it's ridiculous it's again a case of
freedom of speech this man is a
brilliant writer a brilliant comic and
when you watch him he just doesn't tell
silly jokes one after the other to try
and offend it always goes along with the
story and there's always the beginning
middle and end and it always comes
around to well what do you think about
it this is what i think and he does it
superbly the point is he's not he's not
transphobic if we can't he's not
transphobic but he thinks you should be
able to tell what you should be able to
tell jokes about trans people like we
told jokes about everybody and actually
they're funny as jokes
and the thing is the thing is that um if
there are many trans people that don't
that he offends it's very very simple
don't watch turn it off go and watch
something else but there are also
millions of people that love him that do
want to watch him i'm one of them i
think he's
a genius
the thing is it's like
it's simple why do people make such a
big deal about you know what he does you
know what he's famous for don't watch it
simple i think if we can't tell
inappropriate jokes anymore you and i
are gonna have to go and live on a
desert island somewhere with aussie
oh god we might as well live in bloody
russia i mean if you can't laugh
right
you've got to laugh you know then you've
got to have irony you you've got to
laugh with the word the state of the
world right now if you can't go out or
watch something at home that's funny
what are we gonna do you know what i
read the other day was that there's lots
of whatsapp groups now that everybody's
on where inappropriate jokes are told
because it's in secret
and i thought how incredible what a
damning indictment of our society in a
way it is a bit like russia or north
korea or china where people feel that
they have to go underground to crack a
joke okay somebody's upset and you
you end up losing your job or your
livelihood
exactly i mean all the time people send
me things and i'm like where the hell
did you find that you know and some of
them are funny some of them aren't but
it's like who the hell is making all
this stuff but some of it is very funny
sharon fantastic it's it's humor of
course it's humor uh go out great to
talk to you send aussie my best tell him
i'm sorry he bottled it but as soon as
he's as soon as he grows a pair get on
this show and be uncensored for me he
owes me one all right
he owes you big time and i'm going to
tell him he's got to come on and do a
river dance for you yes
he has
i look forward to seeing him uh very
soon sharon great to talk to you i'm so
glad the old man's back on his feet i
know how worried you've been as a family
he is indomitable he's indestructible
unfortunately he's not on the show
but we will see him soon sharon great to
see you all right all the best loves you
bye